[Music]
like experts will study this and say
that you're like what are you doing yes
we will Taylor no you could not fangirl
about that okay so Taylor and Ed are
totally just kidding and we're not gonna
dive too deep into this one but we do
love that Tay Tay had some fun with us
and Betsy at cheerin on Instagram on
Wednesday I just want to start by saying
that this is what he does he tries to
elevate himself just like geographically
so that he can seem to better than me
like experts will study this and say
that you're like what are you doing
you're like peacocking right now yes
everyone analyzes everything Taylor does
but we're happy to see that hasn't
killed her ability to laugh at herself
you never know what it's gonna be
Edie can laugh at himself to Senecas you
with news all the time but what I did
for you today the pair is longtime close
friends heads Georgia Taylor he collab
with her on endgame
[Music]
and game and totally kept his mouth shut
when we asked about the video for the
song weeks before it dropped I don't
know what I can say J don't like but I
like there is a music video for it
[Music]